he came back during that rose ceremony
things were getting kind of tense did
you feel like a punch might have gotten
thrown in That moment when the other
guys walked up I thought maybe because I
know they had just had enough and when
they realized that he had been kicked
off and he just kind of bamboozled them
all and slid into that rose ceremony
they were pissed they'd had enough and I
thought okay there's big dudes tyler
especially is a massive man I don't know
if you guys have seen him with his shirt
off but he's a bit tude but yeah I
thought for a minute so I was there but
more importantly Paulie was actually
even closer big Paulie who security he
is the muscle yeah also what am I gonna
predict guys guys time out time out this
conversation with Luke that we've been
leading up to all season do you think
that Hannah said all that needed to be
said she didn't say all that needed to
be said there that night tonight at the
tell-all
she said everything and I mean she cut
that guy off at the knees I was so proud
of her tonight I mean she owned it
the windmill moment how iconic is that
in franchise history well I mean when
you get the line I've done a windmill
and Jesus still loves me that's a drop
to Mike moment when we heard that I mean
you can't top that in TV I mean what is
that's the one of the greatest lines
ever in the history of television
and yes we did it a second town
[Music]
[Applause]